come on shake come up come up
audiences can expect fun action cars
women but also the American Dream I feel
like that's coming from nothing to
something and also realizing that
everywhere you are is where you're meant
to be and I feel like Chris character
was able to see that he has everything
any man could one in the world but
something isn't fulfilling him so what's
the change his direction so there's a
lot of a lot of themes in this movie
that I think people really relate to
move the operation from my living room
to the church basement from there to an
old garage now I got operations all over
the city it's such an important movie
I'm a source material guy I get very
upset when I go to a movie and it's a
comic book or a book and they change
something so I wanted to bring my
philosophy of that to this where we
really looked at the original who are
the characters what's going on what's
the story to keep the essence of that
but still make it for today I choose my
crew wisely Georgia she's my inspiration
you can be whatever you want to be
wasn't necessarily laid out before we of
course there were african-american
actors but what were they doing in those
films not necessarily being their heroes
at that time but something like the
original Superfly it was seeing someone
who was relatable to them being powerful
and being in charge and that was awesome
[Music]
when it comes easy keeping it that's all
well I think the newer generation should
just be able to see themselves in the
light that they want to see themselves
as a young black guy I've seen a lot of
successful young black kids and they're
like oh it's stupid the one in
Lamborghini or a stupid someone's an
eight bedroom house or whatever it may
be that's over the top a super fly but
in this film
it's a gracefully take that ride you
know what I mean we've had it for a long
time the material yeah probably about
probably eighteen years I've had it we
didn't know really what to do with it
until we met director X and he had a
vision it's got a great feel to it a
great vibe I think it's gonna really
people gonna respond to it
I wanted Superfly to kind of be
everything close in style and hair and
props and everything even down to the
camera even down to the lighting you
make that Superfly
come on let's take a trial
[Music]